there's nothing to fear but Obama
himself according to Republicans a
bottle close is a bigger threat to the
US then Putin a Reuters online poll
vizman past 2809 Americans to rate how
much of a threat a list of countries
organizations individuals pose to the
United States on a scale of one to five
with one being no threat and five being
an imminent threat very Glasair a
sociologist and author of the culture of
fear told Reuters the reason americans
may fear obama is the media's fault
saying the TV here and american politics
very much trade on fears all right so
Trayvon according to my notes here you
are black is that correct as last I
checked you last you checked okay so as
the black person on the panel is this
all about Obama being black absolutely i
mean what come on are you serious more
more scary than Putin what can I more
scary than Putin the guy was elected
twice like why would he be more scarier
than flat Amir Putin a guy who someone
who was opposed of him died right in
front of the Kremlin and the event and
he took over the investigation and they
found a guy two days later yeah and they
were cleaning up the blood before the
corpse even cooled off but like the
crazy part is when they pull these
people was like who are they pulling
because I feel like they're pulling the
same people who are the reason why the
end of a car commercial when a car rides
on top of a train yeah I still have to
put do not drive your car on top of all
right now on the bottom of the other
commercial because it's like I saw this
thing where a third of Louisiana
Republicans think Obama's to blame for
the slow response to Katrina and he
wasn't even present right right there
was some other guy um Jeff uh no your
gorge jumping George W Bush was
president at the time so like I don't
like it's the PI even opposed to me
seemed just like made to drum up that
like let's make a story that I'm so hate
Obama I know when we do these types of
stories you'll always say to me you want
to know more about who the pew of the
people are the day that they talk to and
fall yeah polls are always seem kind of
silly and you know margin of error and
all that
the way they weren't the question yeah
here's the thing like and what I love
first of all first point i love that
we're all talking about how people think
that he's more of a threat than putin
but they also think he's more of a
threat than bush are all right thank you
like so insane to me so there's that
first white so free not in the headline
but the question is not or is Obama
scarier than the question is rate these
world leaders as to how much of an
imminent threat they are to us here in
America yeah and so these Republicans
see Obama as more of an imminent threat
to America because he is the president
of America than they see Putin because
Putin has literally no power to do
anything to an average American so in a
way you're sort of actually giving not
that you agree with you know you're
getting them credit for at least being
true to their principles it won't
believe that this guy is taking the
country down then that's if there was
somebody if there were an American
government like if you were to ask me
who's more of an imminent threat to
America Vladimir Putin or Ted Cruz right
i might say Ted Cruz because Ted Cruz
has power to to affect legislation that
can be very detrimental to our science
policy in the country and Putin is you
know shirtless on a horse like I don't
think that he's really gonna wrecked my
life now I feel horrible for like
literally everybody that was in Russia
right but you have to see those pictures
on a date is just terrible but yeah I
don't think he's an imminent threat to
me as an American citizen this is what I
hope the last year of Obama's presidency
he just wears a hoodie he just every
press really goes just like just put the
hungover yeah I do you want to be afraid
now be afraid so to the fear thing are
you shocked that after six years of this
guy being president whether you agree
with him or not and we all know our
debate is just so stupid in this country
and everyone hates someone or you love
them and there's nothing in between but
are you shocked that the state of race
relations is sort of where it's at which
seems to be a lot worse I was six years
ago when you would not think that that's
the case I don't think in the long game
it got worse but I think in this
concentration of this last six years I
think it definitely got worse and I
think once you saw him get elected it's
no secret why the threats against the
president are at an all-time high in the
history of this country no
presidents ever had more deaf president
obama and all the racist stuff you every
time we've had a racist or any type of
email scandal this year from sony to the
Ferguson Police Department there's a
Obama races email in all of them which
is like why is that right like that's
the uniform write these stories like
they all have to make racist jokes about
the president is like it's it's
everywhere yeah race you think do you
feel the same way like I totally agree
like I think in the long term we're in a
better we're in better shape of course
they're better but we have these blips
where it just seems like right now it
seems like it's much worse yeah I mean I
think that that is to be expected I
think that we kind of all knew that as
progressives going in that if and when
obama won his election and we all were
totally rallied behind him in 2008 at
least that this was going to piss a lot
of people off and sometimes i think that
the slow build is not the way that we
see progress i think the way that we see
progress is we put people in really
uncomfortable situations and they have
to just deal with it and get through it
and i think for a lot of people in this
country who are racist i'll say it obama
was an uncomfortable situation and the
truth is he's been in their face now for
six years they have to [ __ ] deal with
it and the real progress i think is
gonna come when we have another black
president and oh jeez is the other day
is not going away because it will happen
again and when it happens more and more
and more people are gonna be less and
less freaked out about it and then we'll
actually see that you know looking back
on the timeline we're in a much better
place somewhere yeah all right is is
Putin scarier than Obama could we
possibly have another black president oh
my god people are freaking out let us
know in the comments right now